madeleine blé morin sébastien bovet
bonsoir je donne l'adresse on vienne
parler c'est quand même fascinant si
vous voulez voir une image une
modélisation de la planète avec les gaz
à effet de serre c'est donc le public a
accès à pulse par ce point g hgs à thé
point com donc voilà l'adresse dont on
parlait juste avant la pause c'est le
fruit d'un travail d'une pme québécoises
qui envoient des micro satellites dans
l'espace quand même une bonne nouvelle
madeleine et sébastien est ce qu'il y
aura des annonces très bientôt pour la
restriction des voyages on écoute
monsieur trudeau en revient est ce que
votre gouvernement paraît poser une
quarantaine obligatoire aux voyageurs
dans des hôtels à leurs frais quand il
rentre au canada
c'est une possibilité qu'on est en train
de regarder on est en train de regarder
toutes sortes de nouvelles mesures qu'on
pourrait amener pour assurer qu'on est
en train de protéger les canadiens et
décourager les voyages non essentiels
on a eu une bonne discussion hier soir
avec les premiers ministres sur les
différentes options et on va en avoir
plus à dire dans les jours à venir
bon ben madeleine sais pas si c'est
qu'en fait l'annoncent oui en fait c'est
pas non plus tant qu'un parce qu'on sait
que ça devrait au début de la semaine
prochaine
c'est ce que le ministre leblanc nous a
laissé entendre en entrevue sur nos
ondes un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui
la grosse question c'est le quoi c'est
quoi la mesure que le gouvernement
trudeau va annoncer ce qui nous répètent
depuis des jours c'est que toutes les
options sont sur la table
est ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
chaque option à des considérations
logistiques
par exemple lorsqu'on il faudrait
peut-être imposé des tests à l'arrivée
pas seulement des tests qui sont
effectués trois jours avant de partir
mais testé à l'aéroport mais ça faut
prendre en considération
l'approvisionnement en test et si on se
met à tester tout le monde est ce que ça
va mettre la pression sur les
laboratoires provinciaux qui doivent
effectuer des tests pour évaluer aussi
la contamination communautaire ailleurs
le gouvernement fédéral ce que
j'entendais là dans les coulisses et
c'est bien beau
la 6 2% par exemple des voyageurs qui
reviennent qui sont contaminés il faut
s'occuper de ses collègues surtout en
raison des variants là on en a parlé
mais il ya 98 autres pour cent des codes
qui sont nous sommes associés aux
voyageurs et faut pas les oublier cela
non plus oui l'histoire de l'hôtel
obligatoire pendant 14 jours à ce que ça
tient la route rapidement madeleine à
ottawa qu'est ce qu'on vous dit en
coulisses la tulle ça fait partie aussi
des considérations mais j'ai entendu
toutes sortes de choses est ce que ces
quatorze jours ferme
est ce qu'on pourrait attendre par
exemple un autre test avant de sortir de
l'hôtel qui serait amené à aller dans
les hôtels je vous dirais la ces options
là sont pas ficelé encore et on ne sait
pas exactement ce que le gouvernement va
choisir
et ce n'est pas sébastien mauvais aussi
simple que ça non plus d'abord c'est pas
tout le monde vous allez me dire c'est
pas tout le monde qui est obligé de
voyager mais quelqu'un qui est allé en
voyage qui revient 14 jours à un autre
dans un hôtel à moins que le
gouvernement paie mais c'est pas ça
qu'on comprend c'est pas si simple non
plus mais l'idée c'est wydad imposer
cette contrainte de cette restriction
l'hôtel mais c'est surtout de dissuader
les gens à la base deux parties ouais en
sachant que s'ils partent d'abord un
qu'ils aient un test négatif trois jours
avant leur retour puis deux que quand
ils vont revenir vu débarquer au québec
ou au canada
ils vont devoir se diriger vers un hôtel
pi3 4000 $ de plus donc ça fait comme
doubler le prix du voyage d'agrément
qu'on a fait sur le bord de la plage ou
sur le bord de l'océan
donc en fait ce qu'on veut et storistes
pas saisi biais ce qu'on veut vraiment
aller dans ce voyage que non essentiels
et l'idée c'est de dissuadé les gens d'y
aller dans ces voyages donné la belgique
aujourd'hui a interdit pour le mois de
février tout voyage non essentiel à ses
citoyens donc
alors qu'est ce qu'est ce qui est non
essentiels c'est puis en série de
questions et en belgique une déclaration
sur l'honneur que vous faites
en dix ans le voyage je fais et
essentiel je jure qu'il est essentiel on
se fie à votre bonne foi est essentielle
en belgique c'est pour aller voir un
proche des malades c'est pour le travail
notamment
donc on ne peut pas faire ça ici dans le
fond plutôt que le 14 jours au frais des
encans limiterait beaucoup beaucoup
madeleine les gens qui partiraient à la
csu sébastien a donné une partie de la
réponse
justement ça devient très arbitraire en
de déterminer qu est ce qui est
essentiel qu'est ce qui ne l'est pas
donc ça fait partie de la réflexion
encore une fois du gouvernement trudeau
c'est tout un casse-tête ans je vous
dirais ayez vous parliez à dominic
leblanc en entrevue
et je trouvais qu'il avait une certaine
candeur lorsqu'il a dit on entendu la
frustration des canadiens qui ont vu des
gens se dirigeaient dans le sud on la
comprend donc j'ai l'impression aussi
qu'ils réagissent à la pression
politique
c'est tellement important ce que vous
dites parce que oui c'est sûr personne
ne veut le nouveau variant ici la même
taille la cc comme devenue une bourrée
on est dans un océan on sait pas on n'a
pas de couilles on s'accroche après
étude et des voyages en za ça va tout
régler
plein le pignon public monte monte monte
monte monte c'est comme si on attendait
plus rien à côté c'est les voyages les
voyages des voyages des voyages ça
allait me disent tous médias parler
d'autre chose mais bref c'est
intéressant de voir jusqu'où ils vont
aller on le saura en début de semaine
ben oui quand ça règle pas tout ça c'est
ce nom ça arrive pas tous cas rare qu'un
qui en voyage il lui on le sait une
illustration de ce qu'on vient de dire
le pignon public qui est très fort la
chef libéral est pas prête à le
réinstaller dans un poste important d'un
cabinet fantôme
ces batteries et il a redistribué les
responsabilités que pierre corre porte
parole en matière de transport transport
pendant ses coaches cognitive a hérité
de sa propre parole pour la métropole
c'est filomena rotiroti qu'est la whip
du parti libéral et ça m'étonne d'une
certaine façon je vous le dirai patrice
parce que j'avais l'impression que
madame anglais
voulait faire vous vivre une espèce de
purgatoire à pierre arcand et que
quelques jours avant la rentrée
parlementaire et leur et ebay regarder
françois legault a passé vite contenus
riches à st il a vécu son purgatoire
pierre quand il s'est excusé
on lui redonne ses fonctions comme si
elle avait un peu ménagé un monsieur
arcand elle aurait peut-être établi des
ponts avec les députés de son caucus qui
sont pas contents de la sanction qui a
été imposé mais là une semaine dix jours
avant la rentrée parlementaire elle
redistribue les fonctions ça veut dire
que monsieur arca devrait pas les
récupérer
si la rentrée parlementaire puis on
s'attend pas ce qui les récupèrent de
sites ou non plus alors qu'est ce qu'il
va faire il va siéger comme simple
député
puis il aura aucune responsabilité au
caucus de toute évidence elle maintient
sa position madame anglade vis-à-vis de
leur propre tête repartir au chili
peut-être se dire merci au revoir parce
qu'il a les moyens de partir il
toucherait pas sa prime de séparation
mais ce qu'on entend c'est qu'il veut
terminer sur mode alors été élus par la
population gouverneur général en
monsieur trudeau a refroidi grand chose
de nouveau aujourd'hui madeleine mais on
sait qu'ils vont faire attention la
prochaine fois quoi et on peut vraiment
choir devrait pas se tromper deux fois
et surtout dans le processus de
vérification de la corde de du candidat
ou de la candidate qui sera choisie
parce que ça a été une lacune
ce qu'on comprend c'est que bon les
madame payette avait tout un cv un peu à
peu près tous les canadiens le savait
elle avait une feuille de route très
impressionnante
elle correspondait tout à fait à l'image
que le gouvernement trudeau voulait se
donner lieu à des vérifications qui ont
été faites avant qu'elle soit nommé en
poste à la grc par exemple au service de
secret mais il n'y aurait pas eu de
vérification faite auprès d'anciens
employeurs donc ça ça va être la règle
de base numéro un a appliqué la
prochaine fois pour dire qu'on a fait
toutes les vérifications et que tout est
en ordre
et si on se trompe c'est probablement
pas complètement de notre faute non plus
c'est un c'est une leçon là qui a été
donnée à justin trudeau mais je vous
dirai quand on nomme quelqu'un aussi
pour qu'elles cadrent avec l'image qu'on
veut donner mais lorsqu'un problème avec
cette personne l'homme est un peu la
marque de commerce du gouvernement
en prend un coup lorsque justement il ya
des événements malheureux qui se produit
très bien on sait pas qui on sait pas on
sait pas si vous le leur ai dit mais en
fait moi c'est mon cas ne pensez pas
qu'ils n'ont plus rien dire en temps
opportun oui les responsabilités
d'opportunités bon juste être une
opportunité une occasion de faire
plaisir une partie du pays en ne manque
quelqu'un qui vient d'une certaine
région est ce que ça pourrait être
l'ouest par exemple est pas contente
contre justin trudeau est ce que ça peut
être dans l'atlantique osi ce serait
taxée viennent du québec anglais
généralement mais très bien ben merci il
ya une campagne québec pour garder le
moral monsieur legault en haletant
rapidement devoir se fait de la planche
à neige monsieur legault sébastien loeb
et de sakho avec une [ __ ] de neige qui
s'est concocté lui même mais en tout cas
c'est ça c'est l'idée de tous ensemble
pour mieux aller donc pour s'aérer les
esprits pour garder moral très bien mais
on va les jouer dehors en fait semaine
on va essayer justement merci beaucoup à
vous deux bonne fin de semaine
à très bientôt au revoir
[Musique]
faut voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit